um  [Music]  inspiring fleeting trying to rally the  troops  and don't just talk about it be about it  aggressive third quarter again knocks  down the long balls  once the basketball puts his head down  attacks the paint  continues to put pressure on the phoenix  suns and how about this one  look at wanting the basketball getting  me to basketball  i'm rolling get me to touch it gets the  basketball  get out of my way takes advantage 12  points in the first half  13 points in the third quarter look  most points in the paint the last 25  seasons in the playoffs  excellent company again the diesel and  yarns  playing like a two-time mvp right now  mark absolutely  is and sometimes you need the great  players to keep you around  until we catch up the pressure's on  middleton and holiday  they've got see in the last 25 years  most points in a quarter in the finals  game  now belongs to giannis with 20 points  here in the third but  right